david rothkopf is the former director of
henry kissinger's international
consulting firm
in his book superclass the global power
elite and the world they are making he
takes a look at the influence of the 6
000 richest people in the world
he's joined by mark medish vice
president for studies at the carnegie
endowment for international peace in
washington dc which hosted the event the
program's one hour
ladies and gentlemen let's get started
welcome
this evening to the carnegie endowment
for international peace my name is mark
medish i'm the vice president for
studies here
we've come together this evening
to celebrate the launch
of my colleague david rothkopf's
new book
titled super class
the global power elite
and the world they are making
the book was just published by ferrara
strauss
if you don't have it
please go buy it we've made it very easy
thank you very much
[Laughter]
as many of you know david rothkopf is a
visiting scholar here at the carnegie
endowment
he's former deputy under secretary
of commerce he served in the clinton
administration he was managing director
of kissinger associates
he was also the founder of the
consulting firm in telebridge
he's the author of a number of
bestsellers including running the world
the inside story of the national
security council and the architects of
american power
when i first saw the title of of david's
new book
i assumed it was an auto biography
um
which i was looking very forward to
reading but uh upon reading it i
discovered that it was actually very
serious
work
of political science and political
sociology
uh
raising an
extremely fascinating set of questions
about the shape of power
political and economic power
in the contemporary world
it also happens to be a very
entertaining read
populated
by members of the global super class the
new power elite
some of whom may well be in this
audience or or watching on tv
we won't name names here david might i
won't
uh
by superclass david means the six
thousand or so folks
who wield power on behalf of the other
six billion people on the planet
this is a stratum that david
sees as more powerful than any national
government
he argues that the super class wields a
particular kind of power that is of
global agenda setting as he calls it
the book is a combination as i said of
political science and political
sociology and the great american
tradition of sea wright mills
who published the power lead in 1956
reading david's book i was reminded
of an older line from thomas jefferson
who wrote
quote
i hope we shall crush in its birth the
aristocracy of our moneyed corporations
which dare already to challenge our
government to a trial of strength
and bid defiance to the laws of our
country
as david rothkopf reports in superclass
contrary to thomas jefferson's hopes
the new aristocracy is anything but
crushed on the contrary it has gone
global
and it is more powerful than ever for
better or for worse as david is about to
explain
thank you mark uh i appreciate that
introduction and i will use that uh
autobiography line where wherever
possible
um without attribution i'm afraid uh
it's it's a real pleasure to be here
it's a particular pleasure because this
book wouldn't
be possible without the help and support
of the carnegie endowment
where i've had the privilege of working
for these past number of years as a
visiting scholar where
i've had the support of people like
ellie page who's been the research
director on this who's done a fabulous
job and is probably responsible for
everything that's interesting in the
book
um and
for toning down my tendentiousness
and uh you know this is a this is just a
great place and a great institution uh
and a great kind of artifact of the way
a superclass worked once upon a time
when andrew carnegie decided to take 90
percent
of his earnings in his lifetime and put
them into
uh assets that could do good for society
which was an unusual position
one that has seldom been repeated
but you know it benefits all of us here
today
i'll talk for a few minutes
and then uh and then perhaps we can have
some questions and some answers and
we'll get you all out of here by seven
o'clock or before that because i don't
think all the food was eaten
and it's a rule here at carnegie that
you clean your plates
um or it was a rule with my mother it's
either carnegie or my mother i'm not
sure
um
uh but it you know
the origins of the book and the origins
of the idea came when i was going around
and i had done a tour with with my last
book running the world which was a look
at how foreign policy was made
and i got a phone call from a publisher
in new york that said you know we like
your last book and we'd like you to do
another book
and you know i've been trained in
circumstances like this to think quickly
since it's highly unlikely anybody's
going to make another offer like that i
thought that it was you know that i
really ought to move quickly and try to
um uh come up with an answer and you
know i was thinking back on the fact
that i'd probably given 50 or 60
speeches on the other book and whenever
i gave a speech on running the world
somebody would stand up in the audience
and think say that's the trouble with
you americans you think you're running
the world
uh and and i would look at them aghast
because apparently my subtle irony was
lost
in the title
and this taught me an important lesson
and so there's no irony whatsoever in
this title
um
although i try to weave
weave some of it into the book um
but
so that that was you know part of the
genesis part of it was the fact that
when i was a student at columbia
university
back when dinosaurs roamed the earth
they had a
a core curriculum and one of the things
in the core curriculum was c wright
mill's book the power elite and the
power elite looked at how power
uh and the most powerful people
interacted in the united states during
the 50s it was in fact it just came out
of
51 years ago now just about half a
century ago and it looked at how
political leadership and business
leadership and military leadership
interacted just the moment of american
post-war ascendancy at just the moment
when we were starting to have concerns
that would lead a couple of years later
to dwight eisenhower identifying the
threat associated with the
military-industrial complex and i
thought you know
it would be interesting to look to see
whether such a
an elite has emerged for the global era
uh and that in fact it was my sense that
one had and that by looking at this
group by looking at this superclass if
you will we would be able to see
how globalization might evolve because
no group is more globalized
and no group is having a greater
influence on the nature of globalization
than the most empowered people on the
earth and so that's what led me into
this now you know i think on some level
the publisher
um thought that you know we would have a
good audience among the conspiracy
theorists
uh out there and there are plenty of
conspiracy theorists and i and i don't
want to turn them away
uh from this book but just between you
and me it's not really a book for
conspiracy theorists you know i mean i i
all of us have had our brushes with
conspiracy theory i grew up a jewish boy
in new jersey hearing about the world
jewish conspiracy and i thought
great
you know
um
you know
where you know where do i sign up
they're they're they're not many jews
and and and you know conceivably i could
have a significant role
um
nothing
too flashy but you know canada maybe or
world sorghum prices or something like
that but
um
you know
when you examine conspiracy theories
including that one they break down
pretty quickly i mean if the jews really
were running the world we certainly
could have done a better job
uh
uh
uh you know a broadly speaking or or or
certainly with regard i mean the
holocaust the inquisition
the musical stylings of barry manilow
you know what i'm saying i mean they're
things
they're things that we we could have
done better um but you know if you look
at freemasons or you look at uh skull
and bones you know uh you look at these
various groups they break down you know
i mean how can you have an academic
secret society that george bush is a
member of right i mean you know it's you
know it says something about the
academic nature in any event of these
the secret society but uh you know i
think that if you go beyond these
theories
there really is something to be learned
and so what we decided to do was to come
up with a benchmarking exercise you know
a kind of what's the definition of
membership in this and we're not looking
at
uh just the wealthy
we're looking at power and so the
definition that we used was people who
influenced the lives of millions across
borders on a regular basis
now we came up with six seven thousand
people that we could look at we actually
made a list and did a sort of
demographic analysis of them and so
forth uh you might come up with sixty
thousand i don't wanna debate about the
size of the group it's a tiny tiny
fraction
of the people of the planet earth 6 600
we came out with happens to be one in a
million that means one member of this
group for every million people that
there are on the earth but when you get
a group small enough like that you can
start seeing things about the group that
are eye-opening that you know for
instance 94
of the group are men
the single most underrepresented group
in the global power structure to this
day is women and but if you look at
legislatures around the world
the average participation of women in
legislatures is 17
it's it's worse here and in some other
places
but in other forms of power it's worse
still than that i think of the fortune
500 uh there are 13 women right now who
are ceos uh so
uh
that's you know one of the things that
you might pick up from it right now it's
a very transatlantic group 66 61 of it
is from one side of the atlantic or the
other but by far the most rapidly
growing
component of the group
are
people on the asian side of the pacific
ocean and that the center of gravity
within the superclass is following the
center of economic gravity on the planet
so
understanding how this group influences
things
will help us understand what the
implications of a change like that might
be
and and you know
there are other interesting things about
the group too as you look at it first of
all it's an older group
the average age i think is 58 years
primarily white guys primarily people
who are running businesses or financial
organizations used to be much if you
looked at elites in the past they were
much more from the public sector if you
look at the most powerful people in the
world today it is increasingly part of
the private sector
and
we you know we can go further and
further one of one of the interesting
things about it is that we looked at
where they were educated and of the
members of this group um something like
a third 30 percent came from one of 20
universities in the world
now that's kind of striking when you
consider that this is 6 600 people from
180 countries around the world
and most of you know a fairly
substantial portion of them a third of
them roughly have gone to just one of 20
schools and i think that we made it one
of 40 schools we probably could have
gotten it up to half
so what does that say besides you know
can i get my kid into that school
um you know another another thing that
it says is that these knit this is where
networks start to be built
and one of the really defining
characteristics of this group is the
nature of the networks that networking
is the force multiplier
in any kind of power structure because
it gives you access whether it's an
access to do a deal and access to get
insight into what's going on inside a
government and i would go out and i talk
to people i talk to 150 people in doing
this book and time after time after time
when i talk to people sort of within the
heart of the super class one of the
first things they said is small world
and their you know the small world
phenomenon came up over and over i can
get to anybody with a phone call i can
get to anybody with two phone calls i
can get use that as insight that i can
trade upon or insight that i ca or
connections that i can use from the
point of view of influence and so forth
and so
that
you know is is another thing that one
can pick up from from studying a group
like this
some some dimensions of this
are
are are are striking in that they really
force us
to step away from our preconceptions all
of us have been raised and sort of
thinking in terms of
well you know the treaty of west failure
i know most of you right now i can look
at you and see that you're thinking of
the treaty of west failure um it you
know almost never leaves the forefront
of my mind but you know the notion that
there was this treaty 400 years ago and
we started from then on thinking of the
way the world is organized in terms of
chunks of political entities known as
nation states but the role of those
nation states in this particular era has
been changed fairly dramatically and
this i mean we people have been noting
this for some time jessica matthews
wrote a paper
over a decade ago called powershift
which was a very important
uh early acknowledgement of what was
happening here but that power shift has
taken place in ways that are really
really interesting and i think
haven't been taken into consideration by
policymakers in a lot of respects for
one hand the concentration of power in
the hands of fewer and fewer people has
grown and grown and grown
in the 50s when c wright mills wrote
that book the defense budget of the
united states
was larger than the annual sales of the
largest companies in the united states
added up together
today the defense budget is 50 smaller
than the annual sales of exxon and
walmart the two largest companies so the
size of companies is much greater in the
60s the average international
corporation had 100
um subsidiaries today the average
international corporations have 10 000
subsidiaries if you take the biggest
companies a company like exxon has
annual sales that make it roughly the
same size of an economic entity
as say sweden which has a has has a the
19th largest gdp in the world now i know
the difference between sales and gdp
this is just a thumbnail sketch of of of
relative power um but here you know you
have uh you know a phenomenon where
the top
companies in the world
um
produce sales that are the equivalent of
one-third of global gdp
where the top 2 000 companies in the
world have 70 million employees
they probably have half a half a billion
dependents associated with those
employees
and if you add in their suppliers and
distributors it certainly gets you to a
billion people that's 2 000
ceos and boards making decisions
directly impacting the lives of a
billion people on a planet where of the
six billion people on the planet
four billion of them have you know
fairly lousy jobs fairly lousy earning
potential the bottom three billion
living on less than two dollars a day
so there are only a couple billion
people on the planet that are
particularly well employed
and half of them work for those two
thousand largest companies
well you know when you look at the
concentration of power then you say well
well who has influence within that group
well the most influential people are the
people at the top of the pyramid it's
different company by company but how do
they get paid i mean that's you know
that's one of the things that's gotten
they get paid by their stock price well
what influences their stock price well
estimates say that hedge funds alone
because they trade so much represent 30
to 50 percent of trading in markets on a
on a daily basis and of 10 thousand
hedge funds the top three hundred
control eighty five percent of the
assets the top one hundred control sixty
percent of the assets so very very few
financial institutions play a very very
influential role in determining stock
prices which determine the fate of the
ceos and the people who are leading
these companies
power is concentrated in other ways
within these organizations as well if
you take the five largest companies in
the world
the ceos and the boards of those
companies
70 people
are on the boards of another 150
companies
including a third of the 500 largest
companies in the world and almost 25
different universities
so
that the little network at the top of
the five largest companies who have you
know annual sales of about 1.5 trillion
dollars
reaches out and touches an enormous
portion of the other leading companies
which touch an enormous portion of the
rest of the world and so now that's
interesting you know there's you know
there's this kind of i mean there is a
prurient value to this and a lot of the
times i go out and i give a talk on this
people are like well is there a list and
am i on the list and you know how much
money and i loved it by the way walking
in here downstairs and seeing the sign
that says super class sign it
um
and if you signed in down there in the
paperback edition you'll see your name
um
of course you know coming from the kind
of neurotic background that i do i was
like well where do i sign it but you
know this is their separate list for
people who aren't in the super class but
um
you know there is this kind of
prurient value to you know sort of
thinking about big numbers and big
amounts of power and so forth
but of course it goes well beyond that
because companies just as an example are
built to operate on a global basis exxon
has
operations in 180 countries sweden
comparable-sized country has embassies
in 80 countries sweden can vote for the
kyoto accords exxon can kill the kyoto
courts so you know that is a form of
power in and of itself but another form
of power comes from the fact that you
know countries are a little bit like
um you know pets who live in a house
with an invisible fence
you know the one that you know tortures
your dog when it goes off the the
property you know and and and you know
national power is like that you know you
it it can't go off its property it's
bound to the ground and we have seen in
time after time after time as
transnational issues have emerged
countries aren't a particularly good
place to manage them and you know the
the recent financial crisis is a perfect
example of this where uh i was talking
to tim geithner while i was doing the
book who's the president of the new york
fed and he says you know when he is a
crisis what does he do he calls up the
heads of the 14 largest financial
institutions and he gets them together
in a room and he tries to work out some
kind of some kind of a deal with them
and in fact the head of the sort of the
most influential of those which is lloyd
blankfein at goldman sachs refers to the
group as the 14 families
uh which is an echo of the godfather i
mean it's a you know a humorous one i
might add but i mean um
well that's efficient and many people
might say that's great that's a way that
the market you know that's the way the
market can can can work but
um
each one of the people who run those
companies
is legally obligated
to advance the interest of the
shareholders of that company
not the interests of the public at large
and their participation in that
collaborative endeavor
is voluntary it's not um mandated and
that is a gap and now we've seen the
call you know we've seen a consequence
of that gap over the course of the past
couple of weeks as a major area of
economic activity has turned out to be
beyond the reach of regulators and the
the the governance mechanisms that we
have to manage it have proven to be
inadequate to the problem and i my sense
is that we're just seeing the tip of the
iceberg on that even just in financial
markets alone we're seeing the tip of
the iceberg on that because there's 30
trillion dollars in derivatives out
there where people don't know the the
risks associated with it they don't know
who the counterparties are that aren't
regulated in any way and where
disruptions can occur and in area after
area after area where there are
transnational issues the fact that we
have you know governance problems are
you know a big issue you know i think we
have two kinds of international
institutions weak and dysfunctional now
some of them are weak and dysfunctional
but most of them are either weak or
dysfunctional now you know one of the
reasons is because a lot of them use
structures
you know that date back to the second
world war
how do you have a security council that
reflects the state of geopolitical
reality of 1946 how do you have one
without china or india or brazil
um you know how do you have you know a
g8 meeting where you're going to go and
coordinate the global economy in italy's
at the table and china is not at the
table so you know that this is absurd
and yet there must be a reason for it
and the reason for it is that we're
comfortable with it uh you know if you
run for office in any country in the
world and you say i want to cede a
little sovereignty to a multilateral
organization you're hurled into a pit of
lions you know if you're lucky uh
otherwise it can be a much worse fate
and and and you know ceding sovereignty
to multilateral organizations is
you know how it's characterized now i
don't think of it that way i think that
when you have multilateral organizations
you're actually extending your
sovereignty into those organizations in
order to get some influence over global
activities but
that's not the you know that's not the
view of the public at large and that's
resulted in the atrophying of these
organizations or their lack of flowering
and that's created the gaps and into the
gaps have come
informal groups
of the most powerful
to advance their interest now i do not
think for one moment
that you know the six thousand people
that i'm talking about get together at
davos in a room and plan
exactly how things are going to come out
in the year ahead or that they conspire
they're all too self-interested they're
all too self-absorbed and davos is way
too boring for that kind of activity
but
there are a couple of ways that they can
extend their power
one of them
is
when their interests align when they're
self-interest aligned so if
a substantial number of people in this
group say market market market let's
leave it to the markets let's not put
government in the way it does have a
disproportionate influence because they
are more influential than other people
um and another way is that they've got
this kind of agenda setting power you
know i've gone to davos for a number of
years and i've come back
um and people say well
you know tell me what happens at davos
you know and i say well this is the
factory where conventional wisdom is
manufactured
and you know people people go into these
meetings ceos and senior government
officials and so forth and they say
so what's the headline you know which
way is the wind blowing and and that
kind of thing and it seems very casual
but clearly in any society or subset of
society the passing around of ideas and
the arrival at shared conclusions among
a group of super powerful people has
consequences for everybody else
and so
that that agenda setting power is an
extremely important area and it's not as
sexy you know i mean i don't think you
see a new movie you know with tom hanks
you know like you know the you know the
the conspiracy theories movies that he's
been doing you know called you know
attack of the agenda setters but but but
agenda setting is is is really potent
and it's a way to amplify the power of
these groups but you know as you see the
nature of power change and that's one of
the other things we talk about in the
book the agenda setting also becomes
relevant in a different context because
right now this is a transatlantic group
and it has heavily transatlantic values
two-thirds of the members of the group
are transatlantic but by far the fastest
growing membership in the group is asian
um so you know i mean if you look at the
forbes billionaires list just as a
subset of a subset of a subset you know
the three fastest the three countries
producing the most billionaires last
year were russia china and india uh by
one measure china went from six
billionaires to
106 billionaires in the course of a year
now some of that's market fluctuation
but the reality is the power is very
rapidly shifting over there well what
happens if the group becomes more asian
in its attitudes
you know is that a good thing because
that redresses an imbalance because
they're more people there in some sense
it is but if its values neutral
if it's so long as we do business
country to country i don't care what you
do in your country and you don't care
what i do in my country if that's a
shift in the conventional wisdom of the
leadership of the world
is that something that has consequences
for us i think it does and so you know
there are a number of things we talked
about in the book and we get the
question and answers i'm happy to talk
talk about other elements of them where
the nature of power is shifting it was
once tied to the land
it's now much more transient and tied to
institutions over 90 percent of the
people we looked at get a large portion
of their power from some institutional
affiliation as opposed to say a family
affiliation historical uh affiliation so
it's much more transient as i said
before it's much more associated with
the private sector than it was because
the public sector
is restricted in the global sphere and
it's not just restricted in the area of
finance i mean look at the area of
climate change or look at the area
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction or look at migration issues
or look at disease issues it's
restricted and we're you know we're sort
of we're we're kind of improvising to
deal with these things now one of the
trends that we've that has been
important in the context of this group
where we have been improvising is you
know the rise of philanthropy and i'll
admit you know i mean how can you be
against philanthropy right i mean
philanthropy is a good thing and you
know it's great that bill gates and
warren buffett are emulating what andrew
carnegie did in terms of giving their
money
we can't object to that but the gates
foundation puts as much money on the
ground to deal with disease worldwide as
the world health organization does
and you know on the one hand you have to
ask yourself
is that healthy it's certainly not bad
but is it healthy because bill gates
is not answering to a large group of
other people he's not representative and
leaving these decisions to groups that
don't derive their legitimacy from the
consent of the governed which is the
formulation that we've adopted for the
past four or 500 years to measure the
legitimacy of a governance
approach
um that's you know that's a potential
problem it also gives governments an
excuse
not to
uh not to do what they ought to be doing
themselves and so one of the things that
this this raises and i'll wrap this up
here but one of the things that this
raises is that we face in looking at
this group
our future
on the one hand we see very few people
who are much more globalized and that's
clearly the way the world is heading
but we also see a governance gap
because
this the informal or
collaboration of people in this group
has assumed the role
that has been played by formal
structures in the past the other thing
that we see and we can talk about this
more too when we get into the into the
questions if you like is that the system
that has been advocated by this group
particularly over the past 30 years
which is essentially the market market
formulation you know you could call it
reagan thatcherism or you could call it
volker greenspanism or as some wag put
it
you know you could call it friedman
friedmanism for milton and tom tom by
the way was going to be with us today
but he had a death in his family and
unfortunately he could not uh join us
but you know you do you do see you know
a trend in the conventional wisdom that
leaving it to the markets is a good idea
but what's the result been the result
has been a profound transformation in
the nature of inequality in the world a
hundred years ago the richest countries
were nine times richer than the poorest
now they're over a hundred times richer
than the poorest
thirty years ago uh the the
the the very richest country in the
world was something like 88 times richer
than the poorest that was the united
states and bangladesh today the richest
country in the world which is
per capita luxembourg is three times
richer than the poorest country in the
world today um and and the benefits of
the growth have accrued
largely
to
very very few people
uh of the income gains in the united
states in the past decade uh about one
percent have gone to the bottom 90
percent of society
and the the people in the top 1 100th of
a percent of society have gained 112
85
of the wealth of the world is controlled
by the top 10 of the people in the world
40
of the wealth of the world and of the
united states is controlled by the top 1
of the people in the world the 1100
billionaires on the planet earth have a
net worth that is equivalent to almost
twice that of the bottom 2.5 billion
people on the planet earth now you know
i gave a talk on this this morning and
somebody said but the bottom's rising
and yes the bottom is rising but the top
is rising faster now you have to say you
know are you are you comfortable with
this and everybody can come to their own
conclusions but from a purely political
analysis point of view
relative gaps in wealth
have consequences in terms of tension
and in terms of potential instability
and the history of elites and i deal
with that also in the book is a history
of overreaching and backlash
and typically another elite rises up and
says i represent the people and comes
and takes the power the people never get
it um
but
but but
we're at a new point because that's
always happened in the context of
city-states or nation-states or empires
there were legal
constraints that could be thrown over
the the robber barons of the late 19th
century through trust busters you know
and and and the laws that were passed
back then
they don't exist in the global context
there aren't legal constraints that can
counterbalance i'm not saying markets
are bad i'm a pro markets guy i'm one of
the last five pro-trade democrats in the
united states
um
uh
but
that you know we need balance and it's
not either or
and right now the needle is pointing too
much in one direction and it's largely
pointing in that direction because
extremely influential forces have
pointed it in that direction
and we are now starting to be able to
tally the consequences and the
consequences aren't good
for most of the other people on the
planet
and particularly for people like you
who are in the elite some of you are
members of the super class if you buy a
couple of books out there i can
guarantee you'll be members in the next
edition of the super class um
but
you know it's it's very easy to say
things are working fine
but how good is fine and what's
tolerable and is it a sufficient deal to
offer to the people on the other side of
the planet who if they you they were
born with your dna and your capabilities
would still have no chance of success
because
the system is is is closed still for all
the openness and it's still closed to
very very substantial portions of
population a population on earth where
half the people have still yet to hear a
dial tone
and we have to say how do we adjust for
that and it does it suggest
that in the global era
there will be backlash and there will be
developments that are likely to result
in a change away from this westphalian
view a change towards a new way of
looking at governance i don't think it's
going to be hierarchic i think it's
going to be all sorts of layers of
different kinds of governance mechanisms
but is that going to be a defining
change of our time and what's the shape
that that's going to take and what's the
price that we're going to pay in terms
of the backlash that's going to be
required to produce the step forward
that will be involved in actually
creating global governance mechanisms
where we all welcome the kind of teeth
that those neck mechanisms need in order
to be effective and you know i'm hopeful
because i think we live in the best time
in the history of the world and that
progress has worked to our benefit and
as a wind at our backs i'm hopeful and i
look at things like climate change and i
say perhaps that will redefine
everything because climate change is
unique
as the challenges that we face as a
people are you know it's kind of like
you may remember ronald reagan uh once
uh made the remark that if you really
wanted to get everybody in the planet on
the same page announced that there was a
space invasion coming and you know we
would we would find a common enemy in
the aliens and we'd be able to get
together well i think to some extent
we may be seeing seeing that with
climate change and it is one of those
issues where you can't have an alliance
of the willing
you need to have an alliance of
everybody and you need to have
institutions that work for everybody and
so maybe that'll be the catalyst there
may be other kinds of catalysts
but i do know that time is running out
not just you know to deal with issues
like climate change but on my remarks so
what i'm going to do
is
i'm going to conclude here and we'll go
and we'll take some questions
david thank you so much for that that
very uh stimulating summary of your book
first of all i do want to commend you
for all the painstaking field research
you've done
uh we could all feel that you've really
gone to some hardship places uh
you know particularly at davos and
well
they were doing this creature there was
a moment
you know in in a g5 35 000 feet above
the world as i was being served scones
and clotted cream
that i thought somebody has got to
assume this role
and and i you know i stepped up well
done yeah
well done
um well let me exercise the the the
privilege of asking the first question
or two uh just to get our conversation
started and we'll we'll open things up
um i wanted to ask you i i find your
thesis very compelling and sympathetic
as people might say but i wanted to ask
you about
an aspect of it that that also might
appear to many readers counter-intuitive
and even counter trend
you focus on this narrow small band of
brothers mostly not too many sisters
right
uh of the new power elite you emphasize
that the concentration of power has
grown enormously inequality has grown
enormously
uh superclass in many ways is the devil
awares prada of of political science
right i mean it you know the the people
uh
at 41 000 feet determining what everyone
else will wear but the there's another
thesis out there that's very prominent
and and perhaps compelling and and that
is the thesis
uh that really the story of the day is
the decentralization of power
uh after the cold war uh that the
headline really was you know beyond
superpowers that that power in the world
is much more broadly shared
across nations today emerging markets
you you do pick up on this trend
uh
but also people power right and the
power of technology the power of the
internet
some might even argue that we're
witnessing it today in the united states
in a very powerful way in the in the
political campaigns and the obama
campaign in particular many people have
written about that as as a new dawning
of mass power of people power
and i'm just wondering where you really
come down between those two theses and
it goes to your end point which is are
you an optimist or a pessimist i think
can you tell us a bit more about that
well i'm from first of all that old
you know
policy tradition here i think of of
realists
and what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to look objectively at what's really
happening and and and i think that
uh
there is there are democratizing forces
out there the internet has been a
democratizing force some of the people
who are members of the super class in
the sense of having developed a lot of
influence are people who've learned how
to use those tools to to harness people
but there is an impulse to concentrate
power even in those cases
you know and and if you look you know
the internet is democratizing but if you
take aol
yahoo
google and myspace
96 of people who go on to the internet
go onto the internet via one of those
organizations all of which are giant
corporations controlled by you know you
know a handful of people so can so can
you you know i think we can
open our minds wide enough to say that
there are democratizing forces out there
at the same time
as market forces are concentrating more
wealth and power and control in the
hands of a few
and i might add though that there are
also other forces out there that relate
to this decentralization
one of which i think is the decline of
nation states which we've used as as
kind of the central metric and i we say
decentralization but we really mean our
old model is is changing and and so this
is part of it you know that you know if
you could have and six companies that
have annual sales of 50 billion dollars
a year but only
60 countries that have gdp of 50 billion
dollars a year you know that's that's
something you know exxon's profits last
year were larger than the gdp of yemen
and bahrain added up
so
you know that you know that's you know
that's part of the decentralization of
power there are also you know shadow
elites that we look at in the context of
the book al qaeda
you know kind of organizations that are
able to use networking and modern
technology
to project force in a way that once only
countries could do it
so
these aren't mutually exclusive and i'm
not arguing that there is one kind of
power there's another kind of power what
i'm really trying to do is to say
what's the nature of it today and how is
it evolving
and and how should the rest the rest of
the world respond i guess is the next
question
if this is the sort of if you can't beat
them join them question
uh reading your book
i i felt uh again very very uh persuaded
by the analysis but then i wondered
whether i wanted to join the super class
or overthrow it
what what what is the model of response
here do you i think everybody
contemporary man and woman for
citizens of the world what do we do well
i think i think
look everybody's responses you know both
please
you know i i'd like to overthrow them
and then replace them
right
well the groucho marx response you know
or you know
i think in the book i use the woody
allen's response which is that you know
uh you know wealth is better than
poverty if only for financial reasons
but
but but it's you know it's it's you know
i think it's a case-by-case thing
because i don't think you can get
monolithic world government and in many
cases you know i don't think you want to
dissuade
uh the gates foundation from doing what
it's doing i we've always had elites we
will always have elites elites do a lot
of good
leaders in society they're you know i
mean you know
i could understand why the pga would
want to get rid of tiger woods
but there is always another tiger woods
or roger federer or somebody in every
profession so you know i there will
always be groups like that and i think
we have to sort of figure out how do we
harness what's best
and that involves a lot of market
incentives and an alarm is keeping a lot
of those things in place
the question is how do we adjust the
system
how do we fine-tune the system so that
the people who are doing the fine-tuning
aren't populist nationalists who are
trying to lead it in another direction
you know it's a choice between us doing
the fine-tuning or ugo chavez and
mahmoud
or vladimir putin doing the fine tuning
in a way that i think would be less
comfortable for everybody
and i think you know in many countries
in the world we've gone from a debate
which on the one hand was capitalism and
on the other hand was communism to a
debate where on the one hand there's
globalization or globalism or
internationalism and on the other hand
is nationalism and there's a real
tension even in this country today
and and it's produced i i i think a lot
of damage and also the greatest metaphor
ever in history which is this wall
you know with nothing could be a better
metaphor for people trying to push away
globalization than a 700 mile wall on a
3 000 mile border
you know
i mean you talk about
you know an illustration of futility in
action you know but you know you know
my sense is yeah it's bad arithmetic my
sense is that you know you know we don't
get to vote on globalization
globalization is a historical trend
okay it's like you know they didn't have
a referendum in 1806 on the industrial
revolution it was coming you either get
with the program or you don't you can
influence its course but you can't undo
it and that's the that's the situation
here and i think we need to influence
this course now personally i don't
believe that the only metric for the
success of a society is the creation of
wealth
i think that justice plays an important
role
in the metric for the kind of society
that i would like to see evolve in the
world and so i think we as average
citizens need to say are we producing a
system that is just enabling the
advantage to produce more and more
wealth or are we going to create a
system where there's more mobility uh
and or are we going to be satisfied with
what we've got or are we going to find
new ways to address these issues and i
think complacency is something that we
embrace at our own risk because what
will happen is
the the populist the nationalists the
anti-globalist
the the simplistic
will you know to start with the
renationalization of industry and a
whole host of other kinds of things um
that are proven not only not to work but
that are to the disadvantage of of of
global people everywhere
so neither luddite nor lemming
neither luddite nor lemming it says that
on our coat of arms actually
why don't we open it up
adam
if you'd please identify yourself
thank you very um thank you i'm paula
stern congratulations david and it was a
wonderful uh
entertaining presentation and i
understand that you're realist and
uh what you're
looking for possibly is some fine tuning
to get more justice into the system is
that kind of my take away from what you
were saying um from a normative point of
view
um well i would like to approach the
idea of not just fine tuning but finer
tuning
and think about
that uh
change in the the gender
um and would that make a difference
if we had a more
um reflective uh
50 50 or just better than the six
percent of the the women who seem to be
participating in your group of uh six
thousand
would that uh
you feel possibly help advance uh
towards a greater
uh consideration of justice as well as
uh wealth
well look i i as as you know i live in a
house where males represent only 25 of
the
of the electorate
and and a much smaller percentage of the
influence
uh so you know there's no way for me to
answer this question except to say
yes
it would make a a huge um positive
difference
having said that
i do want to point one other aspect out
which you know has sort of been in the
papers recently um it's not exactly
countervailing but it's just a a
parallel illustration
and and it goes to the point that
inequality
is not merely about wealth
if you are as you are
an affluent white woman
you live
uh
14 years longer
than a poor black man does in the world
and an affluent american lives six years
longer than a poor american does so
we're not just making choices about
what's in a pay packet we're making
choices about how
much life
we we even have
but you know all joking aside
the world is always a better place
if the mechanisms of power
represent those who are being governed
more accurately and the world is going
to be severely out of whack
until the people who represent the
majority of the population women 51 of
the population the planet
actually have that kind of influence
over the mechanisms of of of government
for two reasons one
it's more representative and thus
healthier
um and two i'd like everybody to have a
little taste of what it feels like to
live in my house
in the back
congratulations thank you
two questions uh first are there ngo
leaders in the super class in your view
and if so what does it take for an ngo
leader to get there and second how much
of the super class is there because of
oil
um well
first of all you know there are there
are ngo leaders that meet the definition
i mean everybody can make their own
super class list i mean you want to use
my criteria which is the ability to die
you know influence millions of lives
across borders on a regular basis you
know you can ask who does that and you
know i mean
does bono
does angelina
does brad
do brad and angelina together
um and you know the answer in those
cases is you know probably yes uh and
certainly a lot of the big
environmental ngos the gates foundation
their whole host of ngos that clearly
clearly make a global difference
affecting millions of people on a
regular basis across borders and so yes
they make it into the list
oil plays a
very big role
um
in in this there are many
uh you know i mean certainly leading oil
companies both private and also the
nationally owned oil companies uh all
have you know their their leadership in
involved in this both because of their
economic clout uh also because of their
political influence in many of the
countries in which they operate
because of their their impact on
people's lives through the environment
and so forth and i think at one point
you know in the book you know i do say
that i think oil is the most dangerous
mind-altering substance known to man
um and and you know i think that we've
seen plenty of examples of that um
politically um that we are now
having to clean up as as a result of the
exercise of that influence in ways that
has been
detrimental hopefully not irreversibly
detrimental to the environment
here it comes in great book
hello
great book david thank you
um
i have a suggestion for the next book
which
[Laughter]
which should have as sexier title as
this one okay but instead of super class
it should be called misbehavior or
misbehaving
because what is critical here is not the
necessarily the concentration of wealth
or power
it is an oversimplified over simplistic
assumption to think that the
concentration of power
takes you to to the the to misbehaving
because it does corrupt absolutely
the fact is that when you go through the
list
i was quickly
putting a's and c's
on those who are misbehaving and those
who are not misbehaving
and
then went to the underclass and then
found even a longer list of people who
were misbehaving relative to those who
were not
so the the
is the world not
do we not have to go to paula's question
as to be more nuanced
in
corrective action if corrective action
is necessary and come up with lists or
concentration of misbehavior
however we want to define it we're never
going to agree on that well maybe we
will
to come up with a list of necessary
actions to
to address um
um
unfair
something in the world well
look i mean i think
you know you're absolutely right and i i
hope i make the point at the beginning
of the book the middle of the book the
end of the book and throughout the book
that i'm not making a judgment about
membership in the super class that says
that you're necessarily good or you're
necessarily bad or that being having
power is necessarily a bad thing because
i don't think it is now of course this
is my classic centrism which you know i
always thought being a centrist you know
people on both sides would find
something to appreciate in my point of
view
i've subsequently learned that being a
centrist gives people on both sides
something to attack
uh which is unfortunate but nonetheless
i'm gonna i'm gonna cleave to this
approach and and you know and that is to
say this is a book about the nature of
power which some people use to good
effect and to some people used to bad
effect the governance mechanisms are
clearly needed uh as they are in any
community to address
the the the bad actors and the bad
effect i mean we you know we we have a
police department in every town because
people do bad things and we you know we
proscribe certain behaviors and our
definition of freedom is to leave most
of the other things you know open
because we rely in the goodness of most
people in most places i think that
that's going to be true the problem here
is that the bad actor on the
transnational level who is super
empowered
is harder to contain using the
mechanisms that we currently have and so
we need new mechanisms
we need to expand and enrich the tool
sets we have or
the gaps will be exploited
however the notion of doing a book
called misbehaving
suggests all sorts of research
and i will be on the phone to eliot
spitzer as soon as this conversation is
over
uh yes
uh david john price
um i haven't read your book i'm afraid
um that's okay did drunk drop to
conclusions
does religion come into it in any place
uh
certainly when you're writing a book in
the middle of the night oh that's not
what you meant
no
they
they
um
yeah of course and i mean you know there
are uh
4 300 religions in the world
and the
concentration of power effect works with
them is true there are 4 300 religions
of which there are 20 that have over a
million members
um there are only two with over a
billion members uh uh you know is the
pope a member of the super class yes but
there are also all sorts of religious
figures who are using modern technology
to reach out to audiences i talk in the
book about a a latin preacher named luis
palau who you know is preaching in
something like 70 countries
um there are you know there are all
sorts of examples about you know how
religion is growing in the context of
this era and in fact you know the
section in the in the book on religion
the book on religion talks about the
fact that every expectation was that
religion would decrease in influence
but if you look at the biggest religions
of the take the biggest christian
religions of protestantism and
catholicism
they've both grown over the past 10
years
in the world and so the influence of
religious organizations has grown and
those at the very top of that pyramid
are certainly global players
in a way that a lot of national
political figures could never hope to be
so one or two more questions yeah
david wilkie i haven't read the book
either and i i know a remedy for that
i i appreciate that i i hear it's right
out there but yeah the question that i
have for you is what loyalties do you
see
within this the the super class that you
see them are there the commonalities
that you see among the people that you
see also if you could address that too
with what percentage of people would you
say are truly global citizens without
country or nationality in their own
mindset and how many associate with a
particular region or country
well i certainly wish i could answer the
second question because it'd be very
interesting you know it'd be a very
interesting calculation to do um the the
the i i think that even our definition
of you know community and what you're
citizen of has evolved in so many ways
uh that
you know everybody is now a member of
lots of horizontal communities you know
whether it's their local community or
their community through facebook or the
community that they do business with or
the community that they travel to see in
other countries and so forth and so you
know i i think that the old definition
of community is probably the biggest
problem that we face
because we tend to have one set of rules
for within our own communities and
another set of rules for everywhere else
and we tolerate behavior in the global
community that we would never tolerate
in our own communities and when we
change that we are going to go a long
way towards changing global behaviors in
a positive way in terms of the
affiliations and allegiance within the
super class it's like you know any small
town of 6 000 people there are people
who like each other they're people who
hate each other there are people who are
rivals for each other and that's why i
don't put a lot of stock in the notion
that you know you know you get your
super class dakota ring and you go and
you you know you know you speak the
secret language of the super class and
you impose your will but
um
when significant numbers of members of
this group act in a certain way they can
have a lot of influence the 50 largest
financial institutions in the world have
48.5 trillion dollars in assets
that gives them
commonality of interest
an enormous amount of influence
and when they act together it has an
effect on how we regulate how we look at
markets what we say is tolerable what we
don't say is tolerable in those regards
and i think that's what it is i would
look at the super class if i wanted to
sort of look for problem areas and i
would look for pockets of aligned
interest that are leading in the
direction of what hilda calls
misbehaving
you know because most of the activity
isn't aligned and it isn't misbehaving
but there are places where there can be
pockets of aligned interest where there
are that we need mechanisms that don't
currently exist and we could and and we
would do well
to advance them and in fact i think
that's the great
sort of policy and political challenge
of our lifetime in the lifetime of our
children
is is filling the governance gap
globally
okay
one more back there
last question
my name is bill drenin i work for a
small but highly influential
entity known as garden rothkopf
this is this is not a plant
but david i would not i don't know why
you're standing up here go ahead guys
you described the westphalian system and
the user patient if i can use that word
on the part of multilateral corporations
such as exxon and other members of the
superclass
i'd like to hear your views on
the aspect of that system excuse me
regarding the use of force where under
the west valiant system nation states
had a monopoly on the legitimate use of
force and it was one of the way that the
system regulates itself
do you see and i and i don't mean to be
facetious but
to the extent that for instance the
superclass in china the hope is that
as they exercise economic power sooner
or later they will demand to exercise
political power what is to prevent
members of the super class such as exxon
to sooner or later
usurp
what has previously been a state
monopoly on the use of force in other
words do you see a situation where we
have a an army of exxon
no
i mean i certainly see i certainly see
lots of you know examples throughout
history
of corporate sponsored military activity
and it's not new um
i i also see non-state actors
who have the ability to project physical
force in ways that states once did
whether it's terrorist groups and others
but you know use of force is an
interesting area in this regard because
the military elite if you looked at it
50 years ago would have been much more
influential the the reality is that the
cost of warfare today is so high
that
it is a much less influential group
military force is used much less but
even within that even within the kind of
uh the ambit of the of the
sort of military subset of the super
class you see the same incredible
concentration
of power in the hands of very very few
whether it's
the fact that only 20 nations in the
world have missile capability
or the fact that only three
militaries in the world have over a
thousand aircraft
um or
the fact that
one country has a defense budget that's
greater than all the other countries in
the world added up
or that all of the top 10 defense
contractors in the world
are come from nato countries and 85 of
the defense spending in the world comes
from nato countries so there is a
monopoly
or a or or certainly a high
concentration of power of military power
and that i think is another of the
reasons why
it is used much less
because it's so concentrated in the
hands
of justif
of just a few
so ladies and gentlemen the book is
super class please read it above all buy
it and you heard it here first david
ross next year
and reading it just buy it
thank you david
[Applause]
hold
david rothkopf former director of
kissinger associates is ceo of garton
rothkoff an international advisory firm
he's also the author of running the
world the inside story of the national
security council and the architects of
american power
and is a visiting fellow at the carnegie
endowment for international peace for
more information visit carnegie
dot org
[Music]